I was 12 years old when I first got
trafficked my home life was very violent
because of the things that I've been
through in my life being sexually
molested at a young age having a family
member not believe me when I told them
that it happened by the hands of a
family member I felt that no one was
there to protect me and no one cared or
loved me when I was 12 years old I was a
runaway I was just walking around in the
streets and a guy pulled up on the side
of me and asked me if I was okay I told
him I was fine and I started to walk
away and it started to rain
he was like well just come sit in the
car with me until the rain stops I was
cold and wet so I I agree
I was basically kidnapped and raped and
beaten sold for days
[Music]
so from that moment on I just stayed in
the streets I couldn't imagine myself
getting out of that situation
I felt worthless I had little to no
self-esteem I would literally work early
in the morning and I would see kids my
age going to school and it was hard for
me to look at those kids
because there was a lot of shame
[Music]
the one way that I was able to get a
break from the life was to basically go
into a store and still in a plain sight
why my pimp was outside in the car if I
was caught stealing I would eventually
get arrested and I will go to juvenile
hall for most girls or most kids they
will see it as a punishment but it was
structure in my life it was a safe place
and I knew that no one will be able to
harm me my life basically changed once I
was beaten by my pimp and I was in a
hospital for a short stint of time and I
knew that this was my way out I was
turning 18 and there was no more safety
net so if I was to get in trouble if I
was to steal to get away from a pimp I
was going to the county and that was a
whole nother world that I did not want
to be a part of so I took that
opportunity to leave California in hopes
of leaving the life I realized that I
was a victim and then I became a
survivor and now I am a warrior
[Music]
what I would tell the twelve-year-old me
I would tell the twelve-year-old me that
it's gonna get better I will tell her
that your life may seem like it's being
sacrificed right now but it's going to
help so many other women so just keep on
going
[Music]
you